hey guys in this video I want to talk
about ketosis and constipation now I
wish it was Bill cut-and-dry that it
would always be this one thing but it's
it's usually a complex thing that could
involve multiple things so I'm just
going to go through some of the
scenarios that that come up most people
think it's a lack of fiber that causes
constipation that is absolutely not true
in fact a lot of the fiber that people
consume even from vegetables it's
insoluble which means it's not digesting
so adding more will actually constipate
you more so if you look at what you did
before starting this plan and after we
want to look at the big changes and we
want to evaluate each change and I'm not
talking about constipation you had
before doing ketosis that's a whole
different situation which involves
probiotics and a bunch of other stuff
I'm talking about after the ketogenic
diet you started getting constipation
what do you do what do you look at so
we're going to look at the change in
vegetable fibers okay the microbes live
on fiber they will get overwhelmed
easily if you have not adapted these
microbes to this new way of eating so
just like keto adaptation you have to
look at the adaptation of the microbes
that have to evolve and grow to digest
all these fibers because if they can't
digest the fibers you're going to have
this all this cruciferous or kale
shaking you're going to bloat you're
going to get gas if that's happening
then you're going to have to change the
vegetables that's simple too maybe
something like like just lettuce spinach
other types of vegetables romaine
lettuce something like that to get your
greens so just definitely look at that
other people have an issue with certain
types of cruciferous like myself I can't
eat broccoli it tears me up it will
constipate me I can do lots of cabbage
other people cannot do cabbage they can
do broccoli so you're going to test it
out I also recommend fermented
vegetables simply because those are much
easier to break down and pickles are
good sauerkraut kimchi very very good
okay so we have that and then we also
have you know just the fat that you're
eating
the protein in most cases those two
types of macros are easier to digest
then the vegetable carbohydrates believe
it or not but it could be that you're
doing too much fat that's plugging up
the gallbladder and that is backing you
up
so if we look at just the whole
digestive system you have the ability to
digest fat proteins carbohydrates or or
even fiber and just you want to just
check each one of those so so things to
adjust our the vegetable the type of
vegetable may be too much fat and the
other thing is that when you start a
ketogenic diet you will sometimes lose a
lot of water weight in the process lose
a lot of electrolytes so that's why I
always like to add that back in there I
highly recommend the electrolyte powder
that I use because it has a thousand
milligrams of potassium it has magnesium
and as all the electrolytes and trace
minerals no sugar that usually will help
the elimination greatly so even
potassium in general is the electrolyte
to help with muscle cramps and colon
cramping or stagnant colon so when you
have more potassium and helps facilitate
elimination as well as magnesium
those two are electrolytes that are
really important elimination on a very
rare occasion I may have the person make
more water but typically that's very
rare that's not usually the cause but
it's something to look at if you're
eating drinking no water you know that
could be a situation but it's rare the
other thing is that if you're doing too
many nuts or even some seeds which it's
usually nuts
or peanut butter typically if you're
doing raw nuts you're doing you're
getting enzyme inhibitors which means
that that's going to stop your digestion
right there
that could be causing the constipation
so an experiment would be to germinate
the nuts soak them overnight draw them
out in the oven on to lower temperatures
and then consume them and you may find
that that's also a problem the other
thing is just to cut out the nuts for a
couple days and see if that gets rid of
the constipation because that could
block and it also has insoluble fibers
so you've got the combination of enzyme
inhibitors and then you just can't
digest the nuts
the enzyme inhibitors and then as far as
dairy goes so quite a few people are
have allergies to milk sugar lactose
okay so that's the situation and you're
bloating or you're not digesting this
cheese that you're consuming we got to
look at that as well so just kind of
experiment if you have some dairy and
you get gas or bloating then we need to
eliminate that at this time there are
types of dairy that are low in lactose
for example lactose free cheese lactose
usually cheese has very low amounts of
lactose because the microbes consume
that sugar and then they they basically
you get more of a protein than you would
get if you had actual milk or yogurt
casein is the protein in dairy which
that's really high in hard cheeses and
it's also lower in soft cheeses it's
higher in Greek yogurt so you know if
you're consuming too much of that
protein that could back people up as
well back you up so you might want to
try try goat's cheese or sheep cheese
which people can digest that much better
than actually cheese from cows so you
might want to try that as well so these
are just things to look at in your
search to find a solution for
constipation put your comments below hi
guys hey listen I created a pretty
amazing evaluation quiz down below that
actually analyzes your symptoms to find
the cause the root cause of all of your
symptoms the most likely cause so take
the quiz now and we'll send you report